black lives matter co-founder Patrice
colors has been released from her Warner
Brothers deal meaning that she will no
longer produce any BLM focused scripted
or non-scripted content
now In fairness to Warner Brothers
Patrice colors never produced any
content whatsoever during the term of
her deal she she just got a lot of money
and and didn't make anything
but In fairness to Colors no one ever
really expected her to make anything in
the first place
Patrice colors has never created
anything in her whole life the LM did
not exist to create things BLM existed
to destroy and to extort money from
corporations and to enrich the activists
who ran it so that they could buy large
Mansions BLM